bonjour je m'appelle kim thùy j'ai eu le
privilège de travailler comme interprète
avocats de restauratrice avant de
devenir écrivaine les cultures m'est
arrivé vraiment très très tard mais dieu
lui la lecture j'ai commencé à lire
preto mais je suis une mauvaise
lectrices dans le sens où julie très
lentement
il me faut peut-être un nom pour un
livre parce que je relis lèvera je relis
les paragraphes et ce pour bien
comprendre mais chaque livre que j'ai lu
et que j'ai aimé a un impact direct sur
la façon que je vois la vie sam
enrichissable ouvre des horizons
en même temps je suis incapable j'étais
incapable de vous dire exactement
comment je le départ est de mettre le
doigt dessus jusqu'à une dizaine
d'années quand j'allais en italie pour
la première fois pour la sorte la sortie
de mon premier livre je suis arrivé là
et la personne qui m'a reçu c'était
marco et je n'avais pas chercher à
savoir à quoi il ressemblait parce qu'il
avait déjà mon dossier de presse avec
toutes mes photos et ce dont j'étais à
bas il vaut mieux reconnaître à l'aéro
pas et voilà l'une des portes
coulissantes se sont ouvertes et devant
moi il y avait ce beau jeune homme en
ski jeans avec un compte vraiment qu il
ya un chapeau un peu un angle comme ça
qui me regardait avec un énorme sourire
des gros yeux bleus et je me dis mais
quelle beauté et j'allais passer dix
jours en tournée avec lui je me dis mais
comment je vais faire pour résister à la
beauté pendant dix jours parce qu'on
avait pensé 24 heures sur 24 ensemble et
tout ça je me dis ah je vais je vais
devenir d'ivoire une écrivaine chiante
pour qu'il me déteste et comme ça on
avait gardé une petite distance entre
nous et le chien les lois puis tout ce
qu'il dit écoute je sais qu'on est au
monde décembre mais je ne quitte pas
l'italie semble avoir mangé deux tu
l'auras ton
et je pensais que c'était comme les des
rues queen au canada t on peut pas avoir
de dairy queen au mois de décembre
mais en italie les dp déplace à kremlin
citons sont ouvertes à l'année longue et
dont la prix le prix est allé à bologne
pour la première rencontre et après la
rencontre il m'a emmené dans une classe
de gelato et ce n'était pas comme une
place commerciale avec 60 70 saveur il
n'y avait que des saveurs et donc il me
demandait de choisir je dis pas non je
vais prend tout toutes les saveurs parce
que dans la vie on doit déjà choisir sa
maison son métier son conjoint seul donc
est agréable un ca de saveurs jeu
capable de toutes les prendre donc je
dis j'aimerais avoir des saveurs et la
propriétaire était là et a dit non c'est
pas possible parce qu'elle mettait
beaucoup d'attention à chacune des
saveurs dont elle dit non vous allez
manger en corner à la fois et pour
chacun des époux vais montrer seulement
deux saveurs et le premier corner
c'était du chocolat blanc et mascarpone
et j'vous jure ça goûte et le ciel est
le pendant que je je je déguste est ce
mon corps n'est j'ai vu deux hommes en
veston-cravate vraiment très bien payés
en train de les chiffres des cornées
quand est-ce qu'on vous voit ça dans la
vraie vie et je me dis magie dans un fan
tissu island et ceo mac os pour faire de
la petite conversation il m'a demandé
quel genre de musique que j'aimais et je
ne t'ai pas gras de vraiment nommé parce
que je me connais très mal en musique
jeudi à génerville cohen parce qu'il a
écrit suzanne et danseuses m
il a dit j'ai tâché tube on my mind
aisée mais c'est tellement beau que
d'imaginer qu'un esprit comme ceux cus
nous toucher la peau
et pendant que je lui ai expliqué ça et
de se pencher hymne à chanter suzanne à
l'oreille
en anglais avec un léger accent italien
vous imaginez j'étais réellement dans un
monde paradisiaque et jésus mais c'est
pas possible parce qu'ils chantaient
très très bien je ne savais pas qu'il
faisait partie d'un groupe de musique
qui avait été enregistré et qui a même
gagné à des prix tout ça donc il savait
réellement chanter vise ici mais c'était
trop beau c'était trop et dont je me
suis donné j'ai dit non non marco le
premier règlement de se tourner c'est
que tu n'as plus le droit de chanter
parce que je ne retournais à montréal
j'ai deux fils et je dois retourner à
mes fils je dois quitter l'italie pour
retourner à ma famille a donc arrête de
chanter je me suis transformée en mère
vietnamienne très chiante et l'hautil
demandé j'ai dit qu'est ce que tu as
étudié à l'université parce que je
voulais qu'on soit sérieux et qu'on
parle des sujets traités plate et c'est
là où il m'a dit qu'il a étudié en
littérature russe est juste mais
pourquoi et d'asie c'est parce que il
était champion aux échecs au niveau
national quand il était adolescent et il
y avait beaucoup de champions qui était
un russe et donc ça l'intéressé de
savoir un peu plus sur la culture russe
et moi je connaissais rien de la culture
russe et encore moins de vingt
littérature russe
non j'ai dit marco tu vas me donner un
cours intensif sur la littérature russe
edit pose problème donc on a pris le
train et on était et on est allé à milan
pour une rencontre là bas et après la
rencontre à l'université de milan
je voulais faire un autre tour parce
qu'il nous reste une demi-heure avant le
train et l'unité était magnifique parce
qu'il était très vieille et d y avait
plein de d'esprit d'officier le
philosophe de mathématiques ce qui me
rentrer dans le corps dont je veux
encore en prendre absorber le plus
possible de ce qui se passait donc on a
fait le tour et là on n'est pas
si devant la chapelle de l'université et
et j'ai pas de religion aucune mais
j'aime beaucoup le sont dans les
chapelles et dans les églises dans les
temples de seuils donc j'ai dit à ma
cause des démarches qu on rentre dans la
chapelle et là on est rentré la chapelle
était magnifique
il n'y avait personne pour que le son
des parfaits et du coin deuil j'ai vu un
confessionnal et j'avais toujours rêvé
d'aller dans un confessionnal
parce que dans l'est dans les films les
meilleures histoires sont toujours
raconté dans la petite fenêtre dans le
confessionnal et non je voulais rentrer
pour voir c'était quoi est elle à lui et
il était catholique
donc ils n'osaient pas en fait baver
dans la place du prêtre
donc je me dis bah moi je suis pas
catholique donc je vais rentrer vers la
place de prêts totaux vol l'autre côté
et c'est là où il voit dans la petite
fenêtre et il m'a raconté qu'il était à
turin ils sont d'année à une conférence
de presse est en route
il a perdu 1 boutons de sa chemise et
l'aider trop en retard pour retourner
dans sa chambre à l'hôtel pour changer
de chemise et dont est donc cherché une
couturière et le trouver une couturière
avec sa petite machine vraiment un trou
dans me une place tout petit et donc il
est rentré là et la dame s est relevé et
disait qu'elle était sublime et donc son
coeur perdu un battement donc s élever
elle a marché vers lui et elle est
élevée dit tu n'as pas besoin d'enlever
un ta chemise je vais recoudre le bouton
sur toi et donc s est agenouillé pour
lui recoudre le bouton sur lui et son
coeur battait tellement fort que lui il
pouvait entendre les palpitations et
donc ça la tête de la couturière était à
côté du cardon et elle entendait encore
mieux mais encore plus et m'a dit tu
aimes tu sais je suis un garçon je ne
peux pas tout cacher et elle était juste
à côté
et donc il était sur le
déposez tellement l'attention d'un forte
et là c'était une journée en plus très
chaude donc à porter une chemise très
très vieille a tellement usés qu'ils
pouvaient voir les fils du tissu de sa
chemise et si je veux à elles étaient
remontés en chignon comme ça et 10
soudainement en la regardant et le vu
une goutte de sueur qui ont coulé sur le
côté de la nuque de la couturière et il
disait cette goutte de sueur a tracé la
ligne de l'adultère les c'est pour ça
que le livre crime et châtiment a été
écrit et c'est tout ce dont j'avais
besoin de savoir sur la littérature
russe
et là je me dis hein
et alors que ceux du passé et il m'a dit
qu'il est parti en courant avec
l'aiguillé encore accrochés après le
bouton et je suis sorti de la place du
prêtre j'ai demandé mais pourquoi je ne
comprenais pas premièrement il ya volé
leurs aiguilles
deuxièmement il n'a pas payé la dame
la couturière et troisièmement pourquoi
il a laissé passer un moment aussi
sublime et il m'a dit tu sais si tu veut
immortaliser quelque chose d'où ces
éphémères que cette tension là il
fallait laisser aller et donc il est
retourné pour pour laisser l'argent dans
la crainte de porte mais il n'est jamais
retourné la voir parce que où il voulait
garder cet ancien intact ce rêve là
intacte et parce que s'ils retournaient
probablement qu'il aurait été déçu par
la rencontre et pourquoi je vous dis que
c'est la littérature c'est parce que je
me dis que si ce garçon d'à n'avait pas
lu de livre dans sa vie avant ils
n'auraient propre très probablement ils
n'auraient pas remarqué la goutte de
sueur qui a coulé et il n'aurait pas pu
donner une interprétation aussi belle
que de dire que cette bouteille soir
tracé de la ligne de l'adultère et dont
je me suis dit que la ville est la
littérature nous donne le pouvoir de
rendre des choses très banal sublime et
en fait je parle de littérature mais je
crois que là en général nous donne ce
pouvoir de de vivre notre quotidien dans
la joie pour seulement dans la joie mais
dans le ravissement
et donc voilà c'est pourquoi je vous
conseille de lire parce que ça nous
permet de voir la magie dans la vie et
donc avant de vous quitter
si vous n'avez pas le temps je vous
conseille de lire des poèmes des petits
poèmes qui ne dure que trois secondes
parfois mais que vous avez kim et qui
vous donne vraiment le début la faim et
le milieu de l'histoire dont je vous
laisse avec un poème fétiche ne m'a pas
que je répète souvent cela la mantide le
poème d'un poète autrichien qui
s'appelle inde un gento et voici comment
comment il a été écrit je vous le dis je
suis allongé contre vous vos bras
maintiennent vos bras tiennent plus que
ce que je suis vos bras tiennent ce que
je suis quand je suis allongé contre
vous et que vos bras 8e et je crois que
vous pouvez le faire aussi à la deuxième
personne
c'est à dire je suis allongé contre toi
debra maintiennent des mra tiennent plus
que ce que je suis debra tiennent ce que
je suis quand je suis allongé contre toi
tu es que debra 8e voilà c'est le
pouvoir invisible des mots est la force
de la lecture
merci au revoir
[Applaudissements]